robots are steadily improving at many
tasks and even outdoing humans and some
of them but they're still incredibly
clumsy when it comes to fine motor
movements in small joints like our hands
typically even toddlers can blow the
most cutting-edge robots out of the
water when it comes to incorporating
feedback into how we touch move or grip
things for example when you get into a
new car with a gas pedal more sensitive
than your old one you adjust your foot
pressure accordingly your brain your
body and the environment work together
to help you determine the right movement
and execute it researchers wanted to
build robots capable of using this
three-pronged approach mind body
environment to execute more complex and
sensitive movements so they use 3d
printing to create a skeleton like hand
integrating materials with different
flexibilities to simulate the complex
arrangement of bones joints and
ligaments in the human hand
they built several hands with different
levels of stiffness in each joint to see
what kind of behaviors they could
achieve to test the ability of the
skeleton hand to perform challenging
mechanical tasks they had it play piano
music in different styles something that
can trip up even the most dexterous of
humans the hand was able to play the
piano using the staccato technique with
slightly shortened bouncy notes it could
also play glissando where you slide
smoothly between the notes the
researchers analyzed how much force the
robot was using and how quickly it was
hitting each note and they found a
strong match to the force and timing of
a human playing the same pieces while
the skeleton hand did not capture all of
the complexities of the human hand the
researchers see it as a step forward in
creating robots capable of more complex
nuanced interactions with objects in
their environment by taking advantage of
the natural flexibility of the human
hand
the hands could one day be used for a
variety of jobs that require a delicate
touch like picking fruit off of trees or
feeling for tumors or unusual tissue but
for now they'll stick to tickling the
ivories and they might even have a
festive song or two up their sleeves
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]